bengovia's business is being squeezed
from all sides the rent for his small
ice cream factory is about to rise by 50
while his customer base is dwindling
despite being based in one of the
wealthiest constituencies in England and
milk's the number one thing we buy here
that doubled over the last year
um sugar another raw ingredients have
increased the cost of packaging
um that's almost doubled in the last
year the cost of energy we were paying
300 pounds a month now we're up to
fifteen hundred pounds a month for our
Factory and then just the general
economic climate for our customers if
their mortgage is increased by two three
four five hundred pounds a month they've
got less disposable income the bank of
England's announcement of a further
interest rise will be felt by businesses
and homeowners alike as it tries to
bring down inflation from 8.7 percent
for the 1.4 million householders looking
to remortgage this year the news is
incredibly worrying
this is the conservative Heartland of
Southwest Surrey the constituency of
Finance Minister Jeremy Hunt with the
average house price is 1.1 million
dollars it's also one of the areas most
vulnerable to crippling remortgage rates
in this tradition a conservative area 12
000 homeowners are facing average
increases of seven thousand dollars a
year on their mortgages much higher than
the national average when Jeremy Hunt
won this constituency in 2019 it was
with a majority of nine thousand the
question is whether voters here will
blame their financial pain on the
conservatives in the next election
a recent poll indicates yes with support
for conservatives collapsing by 18 since
the last election I've voted Tory all my
life since I was 18. transmute voting
Tory this time is pretty remote
my middle son said to me mum you know
you'll always be okay but actually your
vote could make a difference so just try
and do something different and vote
labor or vote to get the Tories out
prime minister Rishi sunak says he is
completely confident that if the
government hold their nerve they can
bring down inflation this this is
obviously a challenge the challenge that
many countries are facing right now but
we are on it we're on it and we are
going to get through it and it's right
at the bank of England takes a strong
action to bring inflation down they've
got a Target to get it back down to two
percent it's right that they deliver on
that right now the electorate doesn't
share that confidence Charlie Angela Al
Jazeera hazelmith